do you think that he was not co-opted by
the Chinese Movement we were talking
before the show about the you what's
this party the Yuna the united front
this is cool my favorite thing to talk
about yeah and so as you're studying the
united front it's an alliance of groups
against explain can you explain the
united front really quick and then are
you sure I won't go full nerd but the
united front is basically the Chinese
Communist party's political Warfare
department they spend billions of
dollars targeting really who's who in
the west whether it's academics Elites
think tankers politicians their staff
people even in college all the way down
to the high school level really a
pipeline of people who become the most
influential decision makers and Hunter
Biden is a perfect example we were
talking before the show you know Hunter
Biden wasn't really that enterprising in
that the sense that in the sense that
you know don't miss the forest for the
trees right there are a lot of people
like Hunter Biden it's not like Hunter
Biden was out looking to make inroads
with the Chinese Communist Party the
Chinese Communist Party knew exactly who
he was